the White House
wants to take away your beer they want
to limit you
to two beers per week
does President Biden want to limit
Americans to two beers a week
where is this coming from maybe I did
maybe I didn't miss you so much where's
this coming from all right well
uh Dr George Coop who is the director of
the National Institute of alcohol abuse
and alcoholism
says the US May soon follow Canada and
recommend just two beers a week how do
you guys think that's gonna let me tell
you what I'm not going to get involved
in in uh in that in that question right
there I I have no idea I've not seen the
data I cannot speak to this I will leave
it to the experts and not wait the
experts say two beers a week I will
leave it to the experts I'm just not
going to comment on that okay this is a
great Exchange
not because of the beer thing who cares
no one's going to follow this advice but
because of what it tells you about the
experts
and what the conservatives think about
the experts and even what the Liberals
think about the experts
when Peter Ducey asks this question
Corrine jump here gets a little smile
she goes oh here we got the beer
question yeah
Corrine Jean-Pierre knows this is
ridiculous
she knows that there's no win answering
this politically but she also knows that
two beers a week is ridiculous and it's
almost certainly a bogus study and no
one's going to pay attention to it
and but what does she say she says yeah
we um look I'll defer to The Experts all
right yeah okay listen to The Experts
in in a way she is
admitting the same thing about the
experts that the conservatives have now
long thought which is the experts are
often full of it
they're they conduct their studies the
studies often arrive at silly
conclusions and so we discard them oh
yeah well listen to The Experts Peter
tihi yeah whatever moving on she's
tacitly admitting that the experts
are often wrong
but
she won't go all the way
she she's tacitly admitting it's
ridiculous but she's also her
substantive answer is just listen to The
Experts
it's an amazing
very very subtle admission and response
and what it what it comes down to what
the upshot of all of it is I think is
that everybody knows the experts
frequently get it wrong the one thing I
know about science is that statistically
it's almost always wrong because
scientific discoveries and Innovations
end up getting upended sometimes
centuries later sometimes Generations
later sometimes Weeks Later
it's it's a tacit admission that our our
trust in science is misplaced but it's
it's also an admission that the
political ruling class will wield the
supposed credibility of science
willy-nilly as a way to skirt
responsibility
is a way to avoid Democratic
accountability certainly
they'll just use them in a really
arbitrary and capricious way all of that
contained in this silly little exchange
about beer because it's not going to be
so silly when the exchange is about the
next vaccine you're gonna have to take
and it's not going to be so silly when
the exchange is about how you're gonna
have to shut down your business and lock
down and not go to Granny's funeral and
you're gonna have to vote by mail
because covid 23 has come around and the
election's right around the corner
that's going to be a little less funny
about beer we're all going to be
drinking probably significantly more
when that happens but it's going to be
the exact same principle at play right
now go to geniusell.com when you look in
the mirror do you see dark spots they're
not going to go away on their own you're
not going to just wish them away you
need help from geniusell's Dark Spot
Corrector the Dark Spot Corrector has
not one but three Cutting Edge
ingredients goes to work fast on
sunspots dark spots deliver spots and
even old discoloration both on your face
and hands you'll be amazed at how
quickly you'll see results you can now
enjoy what is left of that summer sun
Beach days and barbecues without
embarrassing spots with genucel you will
see the results or your money back no
questions asked go to geniusell.com
right now geniusl.com Knowles get your
dark spot corrector with the new genius
almost popular package say goodbye to
those pesky spots tomorrow really love
the company love the owner Coptic
Christian who left Egypt for the
American dream they're offering free
shipping free returns best luxury
skincare you've ever used all seventy
seven zero percent off all orders will
include a mystery luxury gift while
supplies last janusl.com Knowles
right now go to cinch.com use code
Knowles have you ever craved a nice
barbecue meal with the family say you go
to the store get all the groceries
invite family over and when you go to
turn on the grill your propane tank is
empty well that's where cinch comes in
to save the day cinch is a propane grill
tank Home Delivery Service they deliver
propane grill tanks right to your door
cinch delivers on your schedule requires
no long-term commitment or subscription
plus delivery is completely contactless
you don't have to wait around at home
track the order on the Cinch app from
anywhere whether you're grilling steaks
or lighting up the patio heaters on a
cold night cinches propane delivery
service ensures that you have the fuel
you need to make the most of every
moment go online to cinch.com or
download the Cinch app to order new
customers can get their first tank
exchange for just ten dollars with promo
code Knowles Canada wlas that is
cinch.com or download the Cinch app and
use promo code Knowles
k-n-o-w-l-e-s get your first chance
use promo code nulls to get your first
tank exchange for just 10 bucks Limited
time offer you must live within a cinch
service area to redeem it visit
cinch.com offer for details
speaking of Joe Biden
the Democrat leader in the house
uh Hakeem Jeffries has just come out and
uh he's on the the defense
against the Rumblings that the
Republicans are considering impeaching
Joe Biden
they have nothing to show for their
majority uh throughout the year and so
as a natural consequence of that they
just continue to take orders from Donald
Trump their Puppet Master in Chief who
has directed them uh to persecute and to
go after uh Joe Biden which may take the
form of an illegitimate impeachment
inquiry
pot meat cattle yes obviously very
hypocritical insane that as they're
arresting Donald Trump uh after they
impeached Donald Trump twice over
complete nonsense uh they're complaining
that the Republicans are considering
opening an impeachment inquiry into Joe
Biden when did this all start uh this
started with Watergate when the
Democrats were prepared to impeach
Richard Nixon over nothing and then it
accelerated during the Clinton era when
the Republicans impeached Bill Clinton
over perjury and then
they didn't impeach Bush they didn't
impeach Barack Obama John Boehner said
we're not going to pitch Obama basically
just because he was the first black
president they didn't want to be called
racist and then they didn't they made up
for lost time when they impeached Trump
twice and now the Republicans might
impeach Joe Biden so this is just what
we do now the political opposition just
impeaches the executive this has become
the pattern it's not the exception the
Democrats did start it with Nixon just
as the Democrats started the Supreme
Court fights with with Robert Bork but
the Republicans have participated too
this is the way the system works now and
as usual the Republicans are behind
because it's no longer just about are we
going to open an impeachment inquiry now
the Democrats have already upped the
ante they are now arresting the former
president
they're now arresting the opposition
leader they're now arresting the lawyers
who have the audacity to to be lawyers
and to represent the sitting president
of the United States they're arresting
political dissidents like the five
pro-lifers who demonstrated against
abortion they're facing 11 years in the
Clank they're going to lock up hundreds
of January sisters who committed the
heinous traitorous treasonous crime of
of wandering around the capitol for a
few hours and then going home
it's a sad state that our political
order is such that we're always going to
impeach the other guy now or that that's
at least the expectation but the sadder
fact is we're still trailing behind
we're still fighting yesterday's War
were the the Republicans bring a knife
to the fight and the Democrats bring a
bazooka oh we're considering opening an
impeachment inquiry cool they're going
to put Trump in an orange jumpsuit for
700 years if they don't outright execute
them okay so maybe we should start
engaging in law fair a little bit more
aggressively a little bit more on par
with what the Democrats have already
been doing boy what a great clip that
was now
make sure that you ring that Bell
subscribe to the Michael Knowles YouTube
channel see you next time